Mark: Nooooo it's shards of glass that get jammed.
Wade: What a great intro (chuckles)
Mark: Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier! (Wade laughing)
Mark: (weird laughing) and welcome back to Seven Days to Die.
Mark: We started this off with a bad conversation.
Mark: You don't want to know about it.
Mark: Here's a recap!
Wade: (weirdly Laughs)
(both burst into laughter)
Mark: Oh okay
Wade: I got some vitamins...and a glass jar.
Mark: Yeey. You can shove it up your bum.
Wade: Wha- we can make a video called one youtuber one jar!
Mark: I think there's already a v-video of
Mark: a guy shoving a glass jar up his butt
Mark: And it's not a good video!
Mark: It ends exactly how you'd think it end.
Mark: (still weirdly laughing)
Mark: Okay
Wade: DON'T LOOK IT UP.
Mark: (Laughing)  You can look it up if you want to.
Wade: (Laughing) You don't want to.
Mark: DO NOT look it up. It's terrible.
Mark: Okay
Mark: So uhm uh...
Mark: So we need to f--
Mark: build a construction kit?
Mark: Is what you said?
Wade: Yeah-- okay, I collected...
Wade: wood and stone and stuff
Wade: I'm gonna craft some wood frames.
Mark: Uh huh.
Wade: But then to upgrade the wood frames it says you need a construction tool
Wade: and I don't know what that is.
*Manly Grunt*
Mark: I would guess like a wrench?
Wade: Yeah I would too but uh
Wade: you would have to have like, forged metal to make a wrench
Wade: which seems like a big leap from (laughs) "build this wood box".
Mark: Yeah a little bit.
Mark: (sigh) I don't know.
Mark: Well lemme try to lay out like the uh...
the wood frame? At least.
I'm gonna do this right outside the front door of the house.
Mark: Boink.
Wade: Uh let's, let's not have that
Mark: uhh
Mark: Wait.
Wade: Oh god.
Mark: Oh! I get it!
Yeah upgrading is...
...necessary.
Mark: Holy shit. | Wade: Yeah.
Mark: That's so weird!
Why would upgrading be necessary
and they not give anything that would be the one that could do it.
Wade: I don't know.
Mark: Huh. How do you do it?!
Mark: How do you do it? Do I hit? DO ME HIT WITH CLUB?!
ME AM HIT WITH CLUB?
Wade: Is that.. | Mark: HUHBLUH! Nope that did not work.
Wade: *laughs* | Mark: *grunt* UNGABUNGA! It did not work! *laughing*
Mark: Who'da thunked it?  | Wade:  Huh... burn with fire?
Mark: Maybe. Try burn.
Wade: Burn!
Mark: We burn good!
Wade: Nope, just damaged our own frame.
Mark: *laughing*
Mark: Maybe axe work!
Hitchaa!
Wade: Axe?
Mark: Nope! That not work. It work very bad. *laughing*
Wade: Maybe I use jug!
Mark: Ooh. Jug good use.
Jug, me like jug.
Mark: Jug best.
Wade: Jug. Noo.
Mark: Alright nope.
Wade: Hit tab. Used for bases. Upgrade and repair with wood and a construction tool.
Upgrade more with scrap iron concrete.
Mark: Maybe we hit it with more wood?
Wade: We have to hold... We'd have to hold wood in our hand.. at it?
Mark: Eueeeeee!
It's not workin'. Not workin'!
Wade: Wh-what am I holding?
Mark: It's like uh b- oh you're groanin'!
Wade: *laughing*  A bag of wood?!
Mark: *laughing as well*
Mark: You're very groany about that bag.
Wade: Unghh it was a very heavy bag.
Mark: ( old man voice) Oh man, I need my
exercises.  ( normal voice ) Okay.
Time's dying so-- *laughing* we gotta figure something out here quickly...um
Wade: Mini bike seat? No that can't be it.
Mark: Oh man. Hay bale.
There's like nothing maybe.
Wade: Repair kit?
Mark: Construct- there's no construction tooool here.
Wade: I know it does not make it clear at all what we need.
Mark: Crafting.. character.. map..
Wade: There's not like a hammer.
T-there's a uh garden hoe?
Is that what we need?
Mark: That doesn't seem like what we need.
Mark:  Skills.. this doesn't make any sense.
Wade: Claw hammer! Is it a hammer?
Mark: Hammer? I dunno.
Wade: Still need forged iron for that!
Mark: How would you get *mumbles*?
Wade: How do you skip ahead to forged iron?
Mark: Yeah, it would be in the same thing.
You'd think that the tutorial would have a little more details about upgrading a wood frame.
Wade: Yeah I agree.
Mark: *sigh* Where was the wood frame?
Wade: Man if only we thought to research this before we started.  *laughing*
Mark: Shaadup. We don't need to research nothin'! We got it goooood.
Wade: Uh.. uhh...
How do we make a forge? We have to make a forge..
Mark: Upgrade wood frame.. DURRDADURR.
Maybe.. okay.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna do something
If I build, maybe this frame is like.. place holder.
And you put something inside of it.
like
a log cabin piece, which is something that you can build and a frame is just to outline
what it is.
Wade: Okay, okay.
Mark: So I build uhm..a wood log cabin blocks.
So if I take this
[engine noise]
Wade: A plaaaaane.
Mark: Well no you can just place a freaking--! Uhhghhh.
[engine noise gets louder]
Mark: It doesn't make any sense.
Wade: I think these blocks are useless.
Wade:  *laughing*
Wade: *laughing*  Why didn't we just build our own cabin??
Mark: I don't know. This is so stupid.
There's gotta be
ugh there's gotta be something to this.
It's right click to
b-- E? No.
Frick man!
We're lookin' so bad. The internet..
Wade: It's okay, it's okay.
I built this for you.
Mark: What did you build?
Mark: OOO. OOOO.
Me always wanted stick!
Me always wanted stick!!
Wade: Yes! Now you can jump
on top of wood frame.
Mark: OOOH. This is best.
Wade: Yes.  YES!
Mark:  OOHHHH!
We are best builders!
Mark: Oh we am good builders.
But there's an airdrop somewhere over there.
Ooh I can see it!
Wade: Can you?
Mark: That's not far! We can get that!
Wade: Oh oh yeah!
Mark: There might be so me really good stuff in there. Oh, not wait...
it went behind the hill maybe it's really, really far
Does it show up on the map ?
Oh no !! it's not far !!! It's not far !! It's on the MAP !!!
OOOOOO LET'S GO!
Wade:  OHHH, but with the time of day--
Mark:  WE GOT TIME !!! WE GOT TIME !!!
We can get back !!  We can get back !!
We can do it, it will be tight but we can do it
Wade:  Its a good thing-- we closed the door, right?
So if we just spawn on our bedrolls...
Mark:  Eeeuuuuhhh, I didn't put down my bedroll, I forgot about that...
Wade:  Did we store at all--
Wade:  I didn't either!
[BOTH LAUGHING]
Wade: And we didn't store any of our valuables
Mark: Ahhhhhh, it's fine we'll probably spawn near--
I hit a cactus
We'll probably spawn near here when we die *laughs*
Wade: You hit a cactus that means I'm gonna hit a cactus- uh oh there it is
Dodged it
Mark: We can make it. It's like five minutes- it's right there
It's right there
Wade: Ok. Okay alright
Mark: I see the parachute right in front of me
It's not even a full sprint bar away
Wade: I'm here to watch you grab it
Mark: Ok! Thanks man
Wade: Oh I hit a cactus
Mark: Well that was your fault
Wade: I think learning to craft bandages might be an important next step?
Mark: Isn't it just um...uh...
like brush? Stuff?
Mark: Fabric? Fiber?
Wade: Probably some kinda like, maybe one of these flowers?
Aloe? is there Aloe plants?
Mark: Wait a minute, where'd it go?
Wade: Got it goldenrod...
Mark: Oh it's to the right.
Mark: There's a zombie out here but he's still slow so we should be fine
Wade: Ok
Mark: Just right, where is it?
Wade: Right here, is this it?
Mark: Baa
Mark: Where?
Wade: Here.
Mark: Where are you?
Wade: Right behind you.
I'm jumping
Mark: Oh yeah, oh yeah yeah that has to be it.
Wade: Literally on top of it.
Mark: Ok, alright let me get this guy with my club
Wade: Oh he's fast, oh he stunned me.
Mark: Aaahh
Wade: We're gonna have a good time
We're having a party
Mark: Hehehehehe
Mark: (*singing*) Bea-tin' this zombie!
Wade: Stomp stomp...
Mark: We're gonna have a good time
Mark: Ok, so what's in it?
Wade: Would you like the honors of searchin... Oh
(Mark & Wade laughing)
Wade: Ha - searching...
Mark: I (giggles)
I didn't (giggles)... I thought you said already
That you would watch me open it
You can't act like I'm an ass-hole here!
Wade: Oh, ahh... I don't have a...
location on our house, it's ahh... north
Mark: Yeah, it's north. It's north, we're fine, we'll get it
Wade: Alright
Mark: Alright, there was umm... ahh... Let me see
There's umm... "Macdyvers Book", "Minibikes for Dumbshits" (giggles) and then...
Wade: What?!
Mark: And then a "Spiked Club Schematic"!
Cool!
Wade: Oh! That's... that's... yeah!
Mark: That is good!
Wade: There's schematics
Ooh, that's right... there's... so there's gonna be all kind of stuff
that we... can't build that we gotta find schematics for then
Mark: Ok, so we do have to go exploring eventually
but just [ Wade: Yeah ] maybe not now
Hopefully...
Probably...
It's getting dark, we need to get back
Wade: Yeah... yeah...
Mark: I'm gonna drink this water, the only really water we have
We don't have much else
Wade: My temperature is... is like 90... oh, hello there, sir
How are you today?
Mark: What... what are you doing?
Wade: I'm doing well
Mark: Sh*t, I've been going too far north-west
Where am I?
Wade: Uhh... I'm near you, I'm leaving... the zombie
Mark: Ok
I see the house!
Wade: Oh, do you?
Mark: Yeah, it's right up there
M: Sweet home!
Wade: There's another--
Wade: There's something way over to the right, looks like a pyramid from here but I'm assuming it's another house?
Mark: Uhhh, do we want to risk?
Wade: Do we explore it tomorrow maybe?
Mark: Do we want to risk going for it right now?
Wade: Uhhh...
W: No... but we can
Mark: We got a good 3 hours until... If it's a house we can break in there
And... we can do it | Wade: Ok, it looks like a pyramid
Mark: I don't see, you must have... Oh no, I see it! It's just the tip of a house
Oh, that's the camp! We don't wanna go to that
There's another building over to the right but it's like nothing
It... There's no doors on it is the problem
Wade: Have you been in it?
Mark: Yeah, I... I went there first thinking that that was where you were. Remember when I was like all confused and stuff?
Wade: Ok, so you explored everything except for this unsearched cooler
Mark: Unsearched cooler?
No-uh, you didn't see nothing
Wade: It's full of food! Haha
Mark: What are you talking... FULL OF FOOD?!
Wade: Well, it had a "meat stew", some "blueberries" and an "empty can"
Mark: Well... sh*t... then I didn't do it right, my bad
Wade: Oh, are you who broke the window? You were inside
Mark: I... I wa... I was, yeah
Wade: Ok, so you back at the house?
Mark: Yes, I am. I... I'm gonna be trying to figure out like...
Like what we can craft, number one
Wade: Ok
Mark: "Coblestone Frame", "Coblestone Frame Ramp"
These... these frames don't make sense when you can just build the item. Like why?
Wade: Well the frames are upgradeable, so it sounds like maybe if you just build a wood block, you're stuck with the wood block
But the frame... If we can figure out HOW to build... we can upgrade it with better materials as we go along
Instead of having to just rebuild an entire block from scratch, maybe it's cheaper to upgrade?
Mark: (*groan*) It could be, I... I just don't know what the proper... like ability to do that is
Get... get back home, buddy!
Get back home
Wade: I'm here
Mark: Let's see, I...
Wade: Look at my nice door.
Mark: Yeeah... ok, so
Wade: Please
Wade: I'm gonna have to take... Our neighbors are coming over again.
I... We told you we didn't want any of your, uh, your... your porn soup
Mark: Is that the neighbors again?!
Wade: It's the neighbors again
Mark: Invite 'em in! We got...
Wade: It's ok, she brought a "can of peas" and 2 "bottles of water"
Mark: Ohhh, what a lovely neighbor
Kill her and take it!
Wade: I'd... I... I... I did...
Mark: Oh... well, good!
You always did listen. I learned "Minibike Chasis"
Wade: Why am I so warm?
Mark: I learned... "Minibike Seat". Ok, well that's interesting
So I can almost build a minibike... which is bizarre
Wade: Oh, put down your bedroll
Mark: My bedroll? I did, it's over there
Wade: Ok
Mark: Hab(*fart noise*)
Mark: Ok, "Stone Axe" says "upgrading walls, doors & windows"
Wade: So you can upgrade with the stone hammer somehow
Mark: That's what it says, so there's gotta be a way
Wade: Maybe you... maybe like right clicking or something?
Mark: Right clicking! Look! I just upgraded this whatever!
OH MY GAWD!!!
Wade: Oh, we are the worst. But we figured it out, so we're not the worst anymore
Mark: Ok, yeah. We're on the way to being the worst, but we're not quite there yet
If we still hold on to hope we can be the worst someday
Ok, but this is... this is fine, because... now...
So I just build em' in here so I accomplish the tutorial
Oh oh...
That doesn't sound good
Oh, we're still undetected, it's cool. Don't worry about it
Wade: As I pull out my torch. Hey, we're right here!
Mark: We're undetected, they'll never find us!
Alright, I'm gonna put this like ahh... over in this corner where it's not used.
Wade: Oh, we're sensed
Mark: God dammit!
Wade: We are detected.
Maybe you putting down the giant blocks is what making them sensed
Mark: Oh! It can! You right click! Ahhhh!!
Awwhhhh!!
Mark: Quest completed
Wade: Ok, well we can build some walls around our little cottage then
Mark: We could. This window is open, that doesn't seem good
Hey! Wait a minute!
Ahh, it's trying to get us to craft bedrolls! (groaning)
That was the next step, we're already ahead of the curve
Wade: Uh Oh.
Mark: Oh, sh*t
Wade: Is now night time
Wade: Now things are gonna get scary.
Mark: That's a bad... that's a bad sound
That's a skewy sound
Wade: uh, I put some of my vital stuff in the refrigerator in one of these cupboards here
Mark: Uh huh.
Wade: That way if... if... IF we die
Mark: If, IF! Yeah, if. A very if
Wade: If
Probably not likely but if, you know
Wade: Yeah, definitely not likely, but the possibility's there
(*Mark': High pitched noises*)
Mark: Oh man, I got a umm... I got an "Old Sham Sandwich"
Mark: Made by Shamway.
Wade: Oo yeah lots of Sham sandwiches.
Mark: OoOoO
Mark: We're gonna eat good for a long time.
Wade: I'm gonna try to craft some band-ee-ges.
Aloe cream... cloth fragments...
Mark: Huhh..
Mark: Cloth fragments
Mark: We could probably break down some-uh..
Mark: Oooo that didn't sound good..
Wade: No it did not.
Mark: That..
Mark: Dogs are bad, right?
Wade: Yes, dogs are very bad. They're scary.
Mark: Okay. We're still undetected.
So long as no one (*raises voice*) SHOUTS LOUDLY....
Wade: We need cotton to make the cloth. We better not shout about that, though.
Mark: We.. didn't - didn't you pick up cotton on the way down here?
Wade: Thought I did.
Mark: Yeah I thought you did too.
Or maybe that was another one of the f-f. (*giggles*)
Wade: One of our failures, yeah. It was.
Mark: That was one of our...
Mark: We had a lot of failures, guys. We had tons of failures.
Wade: Yeah goldenrod flower's the only thing I've seen around here.
so we need to go on a cotton expedition.
Mark: Hm.... mmmkay.
*clanking noise*
Mark: Whoa - what was that?
*boards squeak*
Mark: Oh, I got military fiber!
I cr- I salvaged some hazmat boots I found. I got military fiber.
Wade: That sounds fancy.
Mark: Oo.
Mark: Good-good golly. That sounds terrifying.
*zipper noise*
Mark: Do you hear that?
(*silence*)
Wade: The weird ominous... wind...like... horror sound?
Mark: Yeah!
Wade: Yeah!
(*more silence*)
Wade: That's just it though (*laughs*)
Mark: (*also laughing*) You don't hear? Oh me neither!
Wade: No, no - I don't hear it at all.
Mark: Me neither, man!
We're not in danger..
Ooo. what was that?
(to Wade) was that you?
Wade: I don't - I opened the fridge.
Mark: Okay. Good. I heard a thunk. I thought it might have been someone trying to break in.
(*thunk*)
Mark: Oohh...
God dammit! Stop it
Wade: (*giggles*)
Mark: Stop doing that!
Mark: We're good right? It's good?
Wade: That looks good, I think that sound means it's good
Mark: 4 AM
Mark: That's an early time for the sun to start rising, but...
Maybe we're in a weird part of the world
Mark: Okay
bed roll
Wade: *gasps* Oh that's so nifty
and look, crafting
Mark: Yeah, see? Right. Oops
Wade: I'm gonna salvage my bed roll up too
Mark: *making nyeh noises*
Mark: 'kay, I did that
Mark: I'm good, I just completed that tutorial
Mark: so whats- | Wade: how do you salvage a bedroll?
Mark: Er you jus- you pick it up, you go to your inventory, you left click on it and then you- uh
Mark: There is just a skull and a rib cage and a spine out here
Wade: Is that one of the Zombos we killed? Is that the Zombo I killed?
Mark: I dun- I don't know, is that what they turn into eventually?
Wade: UHH I don't know! but that's kinda scary
Mark: I don't know why I found that but wuuf
Wade: Maybe our neighbour came back and left that there for us cos we killed his wife
Mark: Yeah maybe...maybe they were so nice and they were gonna give us all this cool stuff
but then they just, ya know, mysteriously died
Wade: *laughing* They baked us a pie
Mark: Yeah, I'm gonna go a bit north to see...wait, You came from the north right?
Wade: Uh, I think so yeah
No, not very far north
I spawned pretty close to this, I spawned north
uh...west of this by a little bit
Mark: So there's some bigger trees to the north directly
does that mean this it's um
Wade: Just barely into that bottom
Mark: Oh! There's another house over here in like this disaster Biome
We can go over here and try to scalvange uh Scalvange? Sava-blrlrlrlrlr
THERE'S COTTON! COTTON UP THERE!
Wade: Get that sweet cotton!
Mark:  Whowayhoo oh hi, hi nurse
Wait you're not a nurse
You're not a nurse at all!
Wade: *mickey mouse impressions?*
Mark: I wasn't talking to you wade, oh, it's dead.
It dead.
Wade: Ooh I we can have a campfire
Mark: Yes that's what's next. Uhm I'm gonna go into this uhhh
terrible biome and you, you go get the cotton
I'm gonna go and do the desolate wasteland and go into this house
Cause this is a two story house, we may wanna upgrade to  at some point in the future
Woah there's a lot of zombos around here
Wade: I put a campfire down, kinda next to our house a little bit
Mark: Nice
Wade: I'm guessing we gotta get some meat to cook on it or something?
Mark:Uh yeah, that's probably- like once, once we're able to, like, get things killed
which may not be soon
Thunk, okay, that one's almost dead
Wade: We competed the quest chain for basic survival
Mark: You did, I didn't. I don't have any stone for that. Ow, shit
Wade: Um if you hit, um, one of the rocks near our house with your stone axe you can collect stones from there
Mark: Uhhh, that would be helpful, I AM OUT OF ARROWS! I can't get near this goddamn house
There's too many zombos
Wade: I'm coming up, I can help you club 'em
Mark: Woah, this one died really weird
Oh jeez
Wade: Oh you're way this way
Mark: There's a lot of em around here. I'm just gonna dance, I'm not gonna bother killing them
They're pulling away from the house, so I'm just gonna sneak in and...
steal all the stuff.
Wade: I am wet
Mark: Why are you wet?
DON'T ANSWER THAT!
Don't answer that
Don't answer that, let the comments answer that
Wade: Welcome to the daily comment poll, why is wade wet? let us know in the comments
Mark: *giggling* why it's like a, it's like a - a 'Family Feud' style. Give me some reasons why Waade
is wet!
Wade: Ding
Mark: Show me horny!
Wade: What? *Mark laughing*
Wade: I think we'll pass t-t-t-trallicks I don't know who's hosting it anymore
Mark: T-t-trallicks?
Wade: I said Trebek but then I tried to change it last minute
Mark: Trebek never did 'Family Feud'.
Wade: I know! but I don't remember who did before Steve Harvey
Mark: *drunk voice* Jimmy Trallecks
Trallecks.
Mark: Oh man this is (inaudible) Wade: Show us wet - show us horny benna, no that's still the wrong show
Mark: Show us bathing!
Ooh sorry it was all 100% horny
*both laughing*
Mark: There's only one answer
Wade: You guys keep saying the same answer
Mark: It's just horny
Mark: Alright, um, not many supplies in the house there
Urm, this desolate wasteland seems more desolate than I remember
Let's see...
Wade: I'm having some like...is your game stuttering at all?
Mark: No, I'm good
Wade: I'm stuttering, I don't know why
Mark: That's weird considering you're hosting it
Wade: I know
Mark: Hi friend! I'm right here!
Wade: OH JEEZ LOUISE! Hey
Mark: Hi! What you doing buddy?
Wade: Ya know, just being wet in the cotton field
Mark: Oh okay | Wade: I have a little umbrella, I'm 13 percent wet
Mark: Nice!
Mark: Why wet?
Why wet here? There's no wet to be had
Wade: I don't know, maybe the grass is very moist. To use everyone's favourite word
Mark: *seductively* Moist
Mark: *closer* Moist
Mark: Okay, I'm gonna try to find a source of water cos I got some empty bottles I can fill em up
Wade: Oh that's true we need to find like a river
Oh! But you know if you do find a river or something?
Mark: Yeh
Wade: You still have to clean the water
Mark: Wha??
Wade: It's like dirty or something and you have to cook it to purify it or something, If I remember right
Mark: Oh, that would make sense I mean boiling it to kill any germs
Wade: You have to purify the water, so you'd have to do something to purify it
Mark: Huh, but where...
Can that be done in like a......
campfire?
Wade: Maybe I dunno.
Mark: Maybe you need a pot for it - I'm just kinda going downhill but I-I-I- I was hoping there was gonna be a river down here somewhere
W: Every-time I figure out what to do with this game, they update and change everything, so I don't know man
M: Yeah true
I mean I don't even know where to begin besides building a base and then learning how to survive all over again
I know there's gotta be more interesting stuff to be done
W: Oh there are a lot of zombies roaming away from that house you were at
M: Yeah that house was like, infested, I got in and out as quick as I could
W: I see a bunch of em
M: I'm not finding anything
W: What? why am I still wet, I'm in like a desert, dry off already!
M: Don't complain! It doesn't effect you at all, does it?
W: I don't - I think if it get's to a certain - a burp - a certain point it would
M: Oh
It's not, you're not gonna get 100 percent wet. Ooh! Nah, there's a road
Dammit
W: What am I doing that I'm gaining wetness in a desert?
M: I don't know, If It's-It's you talking about it that it's making it weird
W: Ah! I'm at the house. No my mistake
my wetness is still increasing
M: MY WETNESS IS FOLLOWING ME! OH GOD! IT'S CLAIMED THE HOUSE! THE HOUSE IS WET AHHHH
M: Okay, I'm gonna go for this drop, It's kinda far
but I think it's still early enough in the day that I can get it and get back
Wait, we get points for skill?
W: Yeah, that's very far
M: It's fine, I'll get it and get back, don't worry about me
It'll be fine
Trust me | W: I trust you | M: You trust me?
Good
M: good, cos I got water to increase my sprinty
Can I put points in running
W: I dunno maybe
M: Where do I, where do I do that , where's the points?
W: The tab and click on the guy with the hat on, the graduation cap
M: Uhhh, where's points?
W: Well it says cost 10 points and whatnot
So I assume - it says 49 total I have
M: I'm only level 1 still so
W: It says I am too I think, but do you see where it says 49 total points
Like you look and it says cap all - | M: I'm tryna run and beat the clock here
W: That is true, you should not be looking at this screen
M: Yeah, let me do this and then later we can get worried about all the points
W: When you die and respawn I mean when you run and get back to home
M: Oh, you're very funny saying something you actually mean then reiterating it with something that makes me feel better
W: You're welcome | M: Asshole
W: Oh
M: Uh oh
This is bad
W: I knew it, I knew this was gonna end wrong
M: Umm
That's just and inky black sea
What is this?
Oh it's water!
W: *laughing* Maybe that's why you gotta purify it
M: I was very confused there for a second, don't mind me
I -ee- It's like
It's just an ocean of sludge
It's so weird
M: Lemme try to fill up bottles cos the-the thing went behind this body of water here
It didn't - if you see this thing you'll notice it does not look like a thing
Ok, I got water at least
Both: that's good
M: That's good, that's nice, good job Markimoo, ya did it, you're a good boy
W: We need to find Aloe vera plants to make first aid bandages
M: Okay
Where do we do that?
W: I'm not sure, they look like little ferns almost
M: Little ferns?
W: Like a little green plant
I'm looking at a really small picture of it here so it's really hard to tell
M: Ok
Whatever
I'm scavenging some lockers out in the wastelands, so hopefully there's gonna have some good stuff around here
W: Okay, regular bandages only stop bleeding they don't actually heal you
M: There's painkillers, I got some of those, do those help?
W: Uuh, I'm not sure if those would give back health, but they sound like they would
M: *derp voice* They sound like they would, huur I'm wade, I don't know anything for certain
UHH I'm not brave enough to make a stance on my opinions
W: *fake crying*
M: Hey wade, guess who I was right then and there
W: I don't wanna guess, I could be wrong, I'm too scared
M: Ah shit, I'm uhh
I'm full
I'm very full of things
I'm gonna get rid of this sham sandwich and mouldy bread
Something tells me I don't actually need those
Oh shit it's getting really late, isn't it?
W: Yes
M: How far away am I on the map?
I'm gonna keep running
W: Very
M: Oh god oh no
Don't go on without me, whatever you do do not lock the door behind you, let -
Wait for me to get inside
W: You got it buddy
M: Whatever you do do not abandon me to the wasteland
I will be very pissed
W: Yeah, you - Hey, I would too, I would never
M: Yeah, you would never do that right?
W: Yeah
M: You would never do that, cos that's what a shitty friend would do, right?
W: Exactly
W: If there's one thing I'm not, it's a friend
M: Whoa, hey, wait, what?
I could have just sworn I heard the bing bonging from, from dead by daylight
like I - I swear when I was out here it was like
Both: dung dong ding dong
M: Oh man Iv'e been playing that a bit too much
W: What, what is this? why is my guy breathing like- am I hungry or thirsty or something?
M: Breathing? Maybe he's thirsty, drink water
I got a lot of murky water, you want some of that?
M: Wade?
W: Uhh
Oh, I was very thirsty, I'm good now, I have bottles of water
M: Okay
W: Now I don't have any more
M: I got 3 clean bottles that I managed to find and I got 12 murky bottles
Which is good because we need those and stuff and things
W: Oh, I was hungry | M: Glug
W: Man I'm not taking care of myself at all!
M: Yeah, I don't have any food so at some point we're gonna need to make a whole bunch of arrows
M: and just go to town on the animal population
W: Yeah
M: SHIT! My stone axe broke, I was tryna get more stone
M: Ah! My one weakness
W: Stupidity
M: Stupidity *laughing* My one weakness
M: Ah shaddup!
W: So I may have gotten through all our cotton already
M: What? we just got a whole bunch!
W: Yeah
M: What are you doing with your life, man?
W: Crafting myself better armour
M: Oh that's stupid, You're stupid, don't be stupid
W: Yeah
M: Alright
W: If it makes you feel better I crafted you one pair of cloth gloves on accident
M: Thank you but I don't need it I found a bunch of armour on the wasteland
So you made that literally for nothing
DADDY'S HOME
Both: Hi
W: Nice jacket
M: You look so weird in your armour
W: *laughing* Thank you
M: Do I look weird in my armour?
Oh I do | W: Yeah
M: I look like a fallout charcter
Wade: *laughs*
M: Alright I got a bunch of stuff umm
Lemme see if I can use this murky water on, like, this fire in here
Oh, that's not a real fire, where's the campfire ?
W: Outside to the left
M: To the left, ah! Okay
Alright, how about, ooh, bottle water, yes, cook! wait, why can't I cook?
You don't have the required tools?
A cooking pot?!
Oh no!
Oh I got a can of catfood!
I'm gonna eat it
W: Sounds deli- whoa! Hello stutter stutter
Why is my game stuttering so much?
M: I don't know
W: Urm, there's a meat stew in the fridge if you need it
M: Nah I got this, I ate the cat food I'm good
I'm at 54 percent food
I have - I have an ear of corn, on me
W: What
What, why are you...
M: i don't know I - *puke noises*- sorry - *louder puke noises*
that cat food's coming back up me
*vomit noises*
W: Gross
M: Alright, so...
Basics, is it in cooking?
Cooking..cooking
W: You did find some fancy stuff to put on didn't you?
M: I told you I did, why would I lie to you?
W: I don't- did you find anything nice for your old pal wade?
M: Nope
I'm gonna make some corn seeds go, goldenwrod seed, why would I even need these?
So if I have cornseeds we can make corn farm, and start making food
W: That sounds good, do we know how to plant a farm?
M: Not at all, noot at aaalll, I think we need to make a hoe
W: Yeah | M: Do we?
M: Stone shovel maybe?
Nahhhh
We should make one
Uh oh
That a-(gibberish)- is that one of those bad sounds?
W: Yeah, that's the bad sounds
M: Alright okay then
I think that's gonna end this episode here
We'll pick this up tomorrow morning when-
the day comes and we're less terrified, right Wade?
W: Yeah, less terrified
M: Okay so-
Thank you guys so much for watching
Check out Wade's channel in the description
And as always
we'll see you
in the next video
buh bye!